All right guys, so in the final trading strategy video, we are going to learn ABCD trading strategy
This one is just like ABC, but it's a reversal
So I'm gonna explain what it looks like, but let me explain it. So
This is the ABCD trading strategy, right?
Now what is the D here? We know what is ABC, but what is the D here? So let me explain
So we got the A wave, we got the B wave, then we got the C wave, right? This is pretty much it
But then
We got the D wave
Right, that takes out this high
Sorry this low, right? This is your take profit when you
So let me just draw it in a more clear way. So you will get your entry at the retest, right?
or some model block over here and
then
You see price take out this low
And
Then what you want to do is you want to wait for price to go back up again?
And then you want to take entry again from this level and it will go up there
So this is ABCD trading strategy
Let me explain once again. So what we have is a
A, B, C, right pretty much it
Then we wait for the D move that breaks
D, A, B, the low of the B move, right?
And then price goes up
Retest this level or some farewell gap down there and it goes all the way up
Very simple trading strategy guys. So let me show you an example
So
What do we have here? We got the A wave
We got the B wave and we got the C wave, right?
Let me put this like this
Put it like this and bam
We broke this level very nice. So as you can see we
Let me remove that
We got this level we broke this level we reclaimed this level
Didn't quite break the structure over here
But this is a New York session trading strategy and sometimes it couldn't work in the length session as well
Only sometimes okay, so keep that in mind. So as you can see when price
breaks
This level, which is sorry my bad
This level
So you can see we got the A we got the B
We got the C and then we got the D the D takes out the low of the B move the B leg
Right and then it reclaims that level
You can enter on the retest here
Put your stop plus below this low and go for one to two. That is pretty much it
This is a very simple trading strategy guys like they are gonna be
Analysts opportunities for you to enter the market and
As you can see for more confluence, it also broke some structure here, right? So let me point this out
All right, and then we had a
Very tiny imbalance around this level. So let me put this in this it's this very tiny balance that I can see
Let me zoom it in. Yep, and price just wrecked it off this auto blog and it went all the way up
So let me give you one more example